I'm not mistaken we have a quorum now
so representative McGuire the floor is
yours all right thank you so I hope um
everyone has in front of them an
amendment that at the top it's not this
is not an official Amendment it says the
word unimproved at the top and it says
um zero six four seven h plus edits
right so remember when we came to the
public hearing we said we needed some
changes and I went to OLS and I said you
know here are the changes but what came
back wasn't particularly well written
um so
uh you know I think they're quite
stressed over there quite frankly you
know we gotta in my committee we have a
500 page uh House Bill too and and we've
never had one more than 250 pages right
so it's really crazy you know so
um
so I think uh so rather than go back to
them for yet another thing in case you
know because you're probably gonna have
changes also I just wrote in my own
changes and with with the help of my
co-sponsors and and so that's what you
have in front of you so this is not in
any way an official from OLS you know
piece of work this is something that we
took theirs and made changes okay all
right
so
um I I'll just go through it so nothing
from the public hearing has changed in
terms of the concept or the motivation
or the you know what we're trying to do
or anything like that it's just a matter
of trying to get that written correctly
on paper in a you know formal official
way right so
um
so I'll go through the bill uh briefly
and Tony will be here to give you more
details if necessary so the first
paragraph is uh this is the existing
paragraph in current law that defines
who who is in group one
so what's been removed from this
paragraph is state employees
right because because what the bill is
doing standard state employees not uh
group twos and not teachers and so on
yes Peter
on the original hearing or uh
that was always there right but but I
rewrote this paragraph a little bit to
make it clearer okay okay so
yes nothing right it's all about
trying to edit this so it says the right
stuff right so
yeah so
um so what we did was so this paragraph
if you look at the the bill or the
amendment I gave you last time used to
also Define group three that's our new
group right in this paragraph but we
decided that doesn't make sense this is
the paragraph that defines group one so
we'll Define group one and then later in
the group three section we Define group
three over there right so anyways so
that's the main change yeah Dan sorry
one question real quick even
technically speaking old hires even if
this goes through would still be under
group one yes and I think I think that's
implied the way this is written but but
I think you should make that specific
yeah I think so I think you would you
know after permanent firemen you might
say
um and uh state employees hired prior to
July 1st 2024 right so I do think that's
a change that ought to be in here okay
the second paragraph is the one that
makes you make sure that these people
the the group threes count in the
calculation of the unfunded liability
and their employers pay the unfunded
liability payment so that's what the
second paragraph is
okay number two and then from number
three this is the plan right this is the
new group three stuff
um and there's some definitions
um again
um
what's the plan and so on so one thing
we found out in the meantime that that
makes us clearer is that this is a
straightforward 401a plan okay so
there's no two plans or combination
plans or whatever this is a 401a that's
it and both the employer and the
employee contributions are required
right so the the employee is required to
put in his seven percent the employer is
required to put in whatever he's
whatever they're required to put in we
we wrote this such that it's the same as
group one whatever the employer is
paying for group one that's what goes
into this okay so so the money part the
money going into the plan the same as
group one and so
um and so if you ever change what an
employer is doing with group one that
would automatically change you know the
the way this is written just whatever it
is in group one that's
that's what it gets so
um
okay so
um but the plan itself is just one plan
it's a 401a both employer and employee
contributions go in it it's managed
according to the employee's preferences
that's it so that's the simplification
of of um
100 a59 and then real quick um because I
haven't had a chance to look over this
uh vestings immediate
and it has immediate best okay so that
that money is immediately accessible to
the employee
oh well well within within the bounds of
a 401a yes right because you know you
can't take money there's a there's a
later paragraph here which says um under
what circumstances can you receive money
and it's not gonna be right yeah but
it's portable thank you it's portable
it's theirs right there's no vesting
okay
yeah determination you know it's it's
things like death right termination
disability all those anyway okay uh the
members so here's where we Define who's
going in state employees beginning
service on or after July 1st 2024.
um and probably
we should say other than
teachers right so now I look at this
right other than teachers permanent
firemen and permanent policemen right
yeah
right
and
and maybe it should be permanent state
employees I don't know because if
there's
part-time state employees they don't
count right so yeah so so this this
probably has to be fixed a little bit
too
so here's the problem doing stuff
five o'clock at night
okay so you see what I mean but anyways
this is the paragraph that defines who's
in this plane okay
um then we say who's in charge
and
um
uh so you'll have you'll have an
executive director so somebody will be
hired to do this
um and they'll make rules that they need
um and
um
okay the commission so
okay so so I think we need
oh yeah we have it here yeah so
because this is so similar to our
existing 457 plan I uh we decided to
the the overall board that's sort of in
charge we decided to make it the same as
the existing board who's in charge of
the 457 plan now that's something that's
a detail that you could decide maybe we
need a brand new board I don't know it's
just these are people that have been
doing this for 35 years they have a lot
of experience it's a very similar plan
they could put them out to bid at the
same time for for administration you
know that stuff like that so we just
just decided here we decided to make
that board what we call the commission
that's that board the one that already
is there I'd like to say that that board
can
board has the state treasurer the
commissioner of administrative services
um
and and a number of employee members
it's a well-defined board that's that
looks like it's got all the important
people on it yeah and it and it seems to
be doing a good job Etc so yeah
um if I'm remembering correctly from the
Lost public hearing when I was in the
other room
um
did he mention that we wouldn't
necessarily need 541 rule making if we
stuck with that no I I think you do
because you know there's going to be
forms uh there's going to be details
about what does somebody do when they
want to you know say they're retiring
and and leaving and you know stuff like
there's always details right so yeah
um
okay
and and I assume go ahead so it's not
just details but rules are different
than statutes they have the force and
effective statutes but but the thing is
they're very detailed and how you do
things statues in general doesn't do
that so they're going to be rules yeah
no I think I think what you were saying
is those rules might fall under
rules that are already there if we
synced them up but like I said I was
kind of over there so they should
probably be separate
separate sure
yeah I bet if you looked up the rules
that the 457 plan has they would you
know be copied more or less but
obviously there can be special changes
right so sure okay
um
so that's the administration uh the
commission uh this is basically copied
from from the other plans so they can
pull the assets they can hire somebody
to to administer the plan give give
choices to the employees and all that
sort of stuff okay now member
contributions this just says seven
percent it's it's the same as in group
one group one it just in in statute says
seven percent so we just copied that
here
um
it seems simpler than referring to that
other section but anyway
um limitations this is kind of
boilerplate stuff it says if federal law
says you can't put in more than x then
you can't put in more than x right so
um contributions by the employer so
notice we're referring to RSA 100a 16 2
part C so this is
um that's the group one calculation it's
called group one normal contribution
it's currently about two and a half
percent but it's something that that the
retirement system calculates and so or
so we I think it can change over time
and so that's why we made it you know
just whatever group one is doing that's
what we're doing here
okay
[Music]
um
individual Investments so we're just
saying do it the same way that that the
457 plan is
um
and so in the sense that
they would contract with somebody they
would have their own choices there'd be
a limited list of of funds and so on
right the same way the other plan does
and um vesting
um
they're 100 vested so it just says that
explicitly right there
um and then withdraw so there's certain
conditions under which and I think these
come from federal rules generally
speaking but it's um you can withdraw
when you when you terminate when you
retire when you're over 59 and a half
and still employed
um if you become disabled die
um you have some kind of financial
hardship
or there's required distributions so
sometimes with a plan like this once you
reach age 70 you're required to start
taking out like an IRA you know that
kind of thing right so even if you might
still be working
so if we ever had judges in this plan
and we passed that Constitutional
Amendment and they're 74 years old or
something then there you go okay and
then there's a specific reference to a
part of
401a9 this is probably you know kind of
Belton suspenders but it says will
comply with whatever required
distributions the FED federal government
has
um this health insurance paragraph
that's copied from group one it's a kind
of a boilerplate thing it says employees
can can participate in health insurance
the same way they would under group one
and then the last paragraph is about
um
this plan will have some startup
expenses right we'll have to hire an
administrator the equivalent of Craig
Downing uh to run this plan prior to the
fact prior to the date when anybody puts
any money into it right so and and also
it's going to have a relatively you know
the first couple of years it won't have
that much money in it so what we have
here is that the general fund will pay
for this administrator and pay for the
first few years of startup expenses
until such time as the fund itself is
big enough to pay its own expenses yes
and where that front money be recouped
by the state for funding it or it is a
it's an expense yes
yeah
um and just to give you a general
picture
um I was told that we hire roughly a
thousand people a year okay we get a
thousand new hires a year under State
Employment so roughly let's suppose that
their average salary is about forty
thousand dollars so this is putting into
the plan roughly 10 percent of salary so
we're talking about
roughly four million dollars the first
year would be going into this plan and
then the second year you would have a
new four million dollars from the new
people plus you would have uh another 4
million or whatever from the existing
from the first year people right so the
second year of the plan I would expect
roughly eight million dollars added so
now there'd be about 12 under management
right and then the third year let's say
another
10 or so 10 or 12 because some people
are going to be dropping out right some
people quit in their first year or their
second year so you know after about
three years I'd expect there might be 20
million dollars
um you know and and increasing over time
so
um by comparison the the 35 year old 457
plan that has 500 million dollars right
so it's much much bigger you know this
will take time to build up and and our
retirement system I think they're at
maybe 10 billion dollars or something
like that so it'll take a while to to
get to a stage where
um the plan can its own expenses it
makes sense for the plan Zone expenses
to be paid for by the plan
okay
any immediate questions from the
subcommittee
and then you
know you know you go right ahead go ask
thank you Mr chair
um
I would submit that changing this plan
would have a chilling effect on new
hires what happens if the Thousand new
hires that you're looking at don't
happen
okay so what what you're arguing do you
mean changing you mean adopting the bill
right you don't mean changing the way
this is written
saying changing the retirement
retirement I understand adding group
three yeah yeah
um so
so this is
um
so our argument during the public
hearing is is that this is more
attractive to new employees rather than
less because
in especially in this group of employees
there's a lot of turnover
people start their job and and after
only one year maybe I have some figures
I can get them to you but but the the
retirement system their assumptions are
after one year 25 of these new hires
will decide I want some other job right
and then the next year another 10 or 15
percent and then the next year you see
what I mean you know it shrinks down but
the point is a lot of these people don't
last to the 10-year vesting so this this
plan is a hundred percent vested when
they start so it's more attractive to
someone you know in general it's more
attractive to someone who's not sure
what they're doing they're young people
Etc right and people in general go to
lots of different jobs in their lifetime
so so I would argue that it's it's more
attractive rather than less yes
representative McGuire yeah I'd like to
also reply to that
that because of the immediate vesting
this means that the legislature Can't
Screw with their retirements plan it's
out of our control it's under their
control and that's something that
uh as we've noticed is of concern to a
lot of employees and then of course it's
their money so that makes a big
difference to a fair number of people
that it's it's their money it can't be
screwed with it can't be changed
it can't be taken away
so one one thought that I've been having
on it that maybe you can
kind of elaborate on
um
did we hear it all from the New
Hampshire retirement system on we have a
lot of turnover in this group and
typically we're still contributing
employee employee or right the employee
can take the money with them if they
leave but the employer money would stay
in the fund and then would go towards
the uaal because it would be absorbed so
if we go with this system how would that
affect the Actuarial rates
do we have any idea of how much money
that's going to because now the employee
is getting all of it
yeah that's a good question I haven't
asked Mr Carlin that specifically but I
think it's relatively small yeah good
and I have to go so I will turn it on
thank you representative McGuire
appreciate you coming in
over there
call um at the uh the public hearing uh
Marty did say that for this bill
um the effect would be minimal and he
wasn't concerned
um if at some point we were to switch
all the state employees over to this
it would eventually have some issues you
know that issue and also
you know towards the end as you're
winding down the current plan
they're going to have to pay it that the
amount invested will shrink they're
going to have to pay it out sooner
they'll have to go with some more
conservative Investments the return
might be less so if it's some future
legislature decides to uh
to make this much larger it could be an
issue
but Marty said it wasn't a concern he
was not taking a position on on this
bill as I recall yeah and I I'd like to
add that that's one of the reasons that
it's only state employees
because if you decide to be a fireman or
a policeman
you're choosing to work for government
and it's for your career essentially
you know some people may change their
mind
but in general you're saying you're
going if you're a policeman you're going
to work as a policeman for your entire
career if you're a state employee
you can get a job as a
a truck driver an accountant a janitor
anywhere and they are much less they are
not necessarily committing to a career
in government employment and so they
want to be able to
and and that's what the statistics show
that they don't stick around long enough
to vest let alone to retire
yeah representative thank you
um with reference to representative
lakis's Point
um I my one of my major concerns is the
retirees who are in the flan now and
what's going to support their retirement
going forward if there aren't new funds
going into
um go ahead no enough to move funds they
the employees are continuing to
contribute toward their normal
retirement as they have been and their
employer will continue to the normal
cost
and if any the only thing that might
change by the
why not having as many new members added
as before what might possibly be the
unfunded liability but the contribution
to their to their personal retirement
is I mean this the employees are putting
in a lot the employer is putting in
enough to
cover that retirement it's only the the
history that's so big right they're
still forced in this to pay the 10.79 to
the uaal so that portion of it is still
being taken care of so it's still being
the old portion still being taken care
of the old debts being taken care of
they still have to pay that portion of
it but then they're funding their own
retirement moving forward they're not
adding to the liability of the New
Hampshire retirement system and the
the plan
is also
supported by all the teachers which is
the biggest single group in the in the
retirement system
all the police and fire who are still in
the 100 a system so there is no way that
this will cause the
retirement system to consider itself
closed it's still open it's still
accepting new teachers new policemen it
doesn't need to go into the death spiral
of a closed plan and are you talking
more from a cash flow perspective
like well
money going in right now to pay right
now
the retirees are not putting into the
system anymore if I can make a comment
funding to support their retirement or
add in fun item I will say one other
thing that occurred to me and we know
from experience we've seen this before
when major changes happen to the
retirement system there is an onslaught
of current employees who retire so that
they are grandfathered and with them
goes literally hundreds of years of
institutional memory out the doors
this doesn't affect any
current employee
right if they are still in the 100-day
retirement plan
they are not required to put any more in
they may choose to leave and go to this
system but I could imagine that would
only be appropriate for somebody who has
who is a short time I mean they're only
a year or two into it if you ever got a
long time
just on the funding thing
um
so any if you're concerned about people
that are currently retired um what
should have happened is that enough
money was put in
to fully fund right now all the future
expenses of their retirement that wasn't
done and that's being fixed by uh the
mechanism for dealing with the unfunded
liability
so right now for the retired people the
money that comes in to help with their
retirement above and beyond what they
initially and their employer put in and
then the amount That Grew From
investment are the uh the uaal payments
that all the employers are making
this bill
says that even if a new employee goes to
group three or an existing employee
chooses to go to group three their
employer is still on the hook for making
exactly the same payments
to the Past debt to the uaal so that
money is still going to come in to help
fund the retirement of current retirees
I think I think that if I'm
understanding correctly or maybe I'm
just reading myself into this
the concern would be how much money
are the new hires typically putting in
on a regular basis to help the cash flow
Marty had mentioned that 80 percent of
what's getting paid out is what's
immediately getting put in so that we
can leave the rest of the money in
Investments right we don't need to keep
them liquid all of the time is this
going to hurt liquidity so that we have
to pull more money out of Investments
and drop drop the rate of return
potentially
I think in my understanding what he said
and and
um I mean people could contact him and
have him email some information on this
um which I'd be glad to see is uh and I
don't want to put words in his mouth but
what I understood is that this is going
to be a small enough effect that with
the uaal money still coming in it it's
the the effect will be de minimis it
won't matter
um I mean right now something close to
80 percent
of what's being paid into the retirement
system for current employees is the uaal
and that's still going to go in
uh even with this change
um and I don't know if you'd have any
idea on this Tony the other thing that I
was wondering
does the definition of pension shift
here as far as the windfall act would be
concerned
um so because they're still they're
still paying into Social Security on top
of what they're putting into the
retirement system right so they're not
gonna they're not gonna lose Social
Security benefits like they would under
the regular pension well that's not
necessarily true yeah it's so it happens
I mean I'm in that situation
um I get Social Security and I also am
living partly on money I'm pulling out
of a 401k and IRAs
um you know when you do your taxes you
report that income that unless it's a
Roth where you've already paid taxes but
I've got traditional
you the you will have part of your
Social Security benefits tax just based
on your total income
but my understanding is that's the same
whether that income is being pulled out
of an IRA or you're getting it from a
pension so I don't think it's going to
make a difference and Carol correct me
you may yeah the windfall act applies
specifically to people who have a
pension earned while they were not
paying into Social Security which in
this case is group two okay so it never
applies to group one anyway
IRS penalties for having earning too
much but there's nothing we can do about
it sure yeah Peter
so uh this was alluded to just a moment
ago but uh the tax return and tax filing
aspect of it is something that we need
to think through because uh some people
have a pretty simple estate or pretty uh
simple Holdings uh and they may still be
doing their own taxes okay but to what
degree is this going to make uh tax
filing a lot more complicated so people
are going to go like uh I can't figure
this out anymore now I'm going to have
to pay an accountant I think I'm not
saying this is going to be different I
use an accountant because I got a kind
of a complicated situation but what what
are the answers here so the difference
is that if you are receiving a
traditional pension which I am you get a
1099 P that says your pension was
so much this year and so much of it is
taxable if you get this will give you a
statement from your retirement from the
from the system saying you withdrew so
much
from the from the plan and it's all
taxable it's one line on the
you'll still it should not be that much
more difficult right I mean if you're
using
um you could do it yourself you're going
to enter it on a different line or if
you're using TurboTax or the H R Block
app you know they ask the questions you
put it in it goes on a different line of
form but it's the number just is a
different line and that's all the other
thing is um there's from a tax
standpoint there is actually another
advantage
to doing it this way and that is each
year you have a choice as to how much
money you're going to withdraw as long
as it's at least the minimum required
distribution and what that means is
let's say
you know one year you have some other
income uh you know maybe from an
investment or maybe you worked part-time
or whatever you can choose that year to
take less out of your your 401a or
whatever this is
um
but if a pension you're going to get the
same amount of money every year and that
means you know you may end up in a
higher tax bracket whereas with this you
have a choice within you know with a
plur but you have a choice as to how
much you take out you may be able to
avoid paying additional taxes because
one year you had more income for some
reason
foreign
I'm not objecting to it on that basis I
just think we need to think through it
and make the argument so people know up
front they want to be transparent right
right uh so they know up front this is
what I'm going to get this is going to
this these are additional complications
if any and so forth so that we have
addressed that so people are not going
well is there any water in the pool
before I jump off this diving board I I
do my own taxes
um I actually use Turbo Tax but
with the statement from your the money
you withdrawn from an IRA or 401K
it actually tells you you know
which things you need to enter and it
gives you some idea of where
um so it's it's no more complicated one
or the other you have to you know
sure Diane one more
I apologize for being late I couldn't
get the ice off my windshield I came in
as the
presenter the prime sponsor was talking
about the health care costs under this
plan
and that was a concern of mine also that
the original bill and the Amendments
that were presented originally say that
the health care costs would be paid by
these new employees at their own expense
which is exactly what happens with
current employees at from group one who
state employees who are retired they
have to deal with the there's a subsidy
but they have to contribute to
contribute to it and
um it the wording in the amendment was
taken exactly from the
um group one yeah we included to hear
because if we if we didn't
um then the group three people wouldn't
be able to do it but we're letting them
continue exactly the same thing they
have now so it still has a subsidy
with the depends on what the legislature
feels like doing but but it refers if
you look at it this is uh on the last
page 1871
it um it refers back to two sections you
know or a number of sections in RSA 21 I
which defines the plan they have now so
it just says they're eligible for the
same plan under the same terms as uh you
know group one
that's what it says unless otherwise
provided but it would be dependent on
what I believe it's the finance fiscal
committee that vaccines as our current
retirees okay and
is there a way that we can tell whether
that subsidy would still be viable with
this new plan
it shouldn't make any difference
because my mind my understanding and
Marty's actually testified this and I
think on another bill
um the retirement nhrs has nothing to do
with that whole health insurance group
thing so it can't have any impact on it
I realize that it's all determined by
the fiscal committee but it's dependent
on the amount of money that's available
but it's not available in the retirement
system it's I assume no it's all set by
by
the legislature and the budget by Das
and fiscal to finalize it but it's it
shouldn't make any difference what group
they're in
right we just want to make sure they
won't fund it
we just wanted to make sure it was
available to the people that were put
into group three as well so they weren't
losing it under the same precarious
condition group one yeah yeah you'd have
to
come to the conclusion that some reason
fiscal would continue to allow group one
to do it but would exclude group three
I'm not even sure they could do that
although they can I'm just saying what
the rationale would be you know that's
what we'd have to wrap our mind around
why would they do that right and more
likely would be an abort across the
board cut yeah I would assume so
representative true
thank you Mr chair
um I don't think I've got any questions
on the pensions at all but there might
be a few people and I like to ask
questions to clear up for them poor
people thank you so much representative
um the commission the commission uh
uh we'll we'll run the pension plan
it's not a pension plan
but it's a uh it's a defined
contribution plan right so you don't get
a pension so right so is there a cost
for the commission
I mean there will be some costs not only
for
whatever employees are in the commission
I mean one thing is we're the board
we're using the existing ones we're not
standing up another whole board and the
cost for that but the costs and there
will be a cause for the commission
um I assume there's going to be some
employee portal so there'd be some cost
you know I.T cost to getting that set up
and then the other thing the way this I
think the existing plan works the 101b
plan
is the plan in RSA 101b is uh they
generally will contract out with some
outfit to actually handle the management
of the funds and the investment all that
I mean like when I was working for a
private company I had a 401k and the
company contracted with Fidelity to
handle the whole thing and there's other
vendors will do that so there will be
costs
when they contract that out to to pay
for
that management of the Investments okay
and the way this is written is that
after the first three years the cost of
that will be paid for by the fund the
problem is two problems one is until
there's a reasonable amount of money in
it the percentage of what's in the fund
that it would take to administer it
would be high enough that the returns
would be very poor and second of all we
heard testimony from I think that the
I'm the fellow runs the uh the current
uh to find yeah
um he said that
if there isn't a guarantee for payment
for the management on the startup end
until there's money in there that
nobody's going to bid on it
and so that is the reason for
um you know paying the administrative
costs for the first about three years
yeah go ahead how about you got 27. only
27 yeah
we may have to we have to cut a few of
them short I thought the first the first
Speaker said that um they would have to
hire somebody
right but that would be there would be
hiring Fidelity well no it could be
it'll be both I mean you're going to
have some employees working for the
state to oversee it
I mean if you're gonna if you're gonna
contract something somebody's got to
write the RFP and somebody's got to
oversee the contract and then there will
be some work in the state because the
um there'll be at least some employee
portal probably the state will have
maybe they'll all be contracted out I
don't know but there will be some work
that the state will do
um and maybe most of it will be done by
the contractor but where that split is
up to
you know how they write the contract yes
and also you'll you'll have somebody who
needs to write the rules and answer
questions
so that's something that you would
probably want to have an employee
available to do that it might be that we
the administrator of the 457 plan gets
an assistant or a rule writer or
something like that to start up but
there will be some overhead in the in
the in the we're not expecting that to
be large and it's like you know again I
work for a company and uh the HR
department that benefits people
um
handled some stuff around the 401K plan
I mean they they did training you know
provided training materials the
employees
um there were people who could ask if
you had problems somebody to contact but
the bulk of what we did
you know like setting how we wanted to
Investments and all that I mean actually
went we could go to a company portal but
all that did was send us off to Fidelity
so there was a small part that's in was
in the company but most of it was
Fidelity I expect similar situation here
and you are you are tying that to the
457 correct that's what Dan said yeah
it's all the same program
um
uh just for clarification so the money
that we're putting in initially which he
said could be over the next few years
upwards of 20 million or so no no no
what he was saying there was that oh
just that it would that within a few
years he expected the fun contributions
the fund would be about around 20
minutes okay gotcha and and the idea is
in that amount of time
um you know the fund will have enough
money that it can pay the expenses and
still have the employees get a
reasonable return on their investment
and as it grows presumably the
um you know the percentage of the
administrative costs
as a percentage of the whole fund as the
fund growth would actually go down
yeah Chris
um thank you
so as long as a new employee
is under the 401 whatever plan
the the employee deployer and the
employer the state will be paying into
the ual
correct
but if that person leaves
they're not paying for that ghost person
that's true today if you have somebody
who's in the pension system and they
leave I mean the ual is paid on as I
understand it a percentage of gross
payroll
and if that goes down because an
employee is not getting paid because
they love then the obligation towards El
will go down
my other 47 questions
so the the employee is paying seven
percent in does the employer pay in yeah
2.48 yeah 2.48 right
plus the plus the uh plus the 10.79 the
uaal goes to goes into the
New Hampshire retirement system and it's
managed along with the rest of the
payments for the retirees and the people
who are in the existing plans
the the two and a half percent goes into
the into this plan to be and men's
managed by by the employee it is vested
immediately right and we left it we put
in that that's the minimum so that
people could negotiate
could negotiate for a higher match or
whatever
we think that the current amount is
barely adequate and so we would like we
would want to have people either well we
would like to have people save on their
own on the Deferred Compensation Plan
and we'd like to encourage the employer
to contribute more but
and as a start we're putting in the same
amount of diet plan
yeah we changed actually in this most
recent draft that they have to
contribute
equal to or greater than the amount
they're currently contributing to the uh
um that they do for any group on
employee
the normal cost right
all right well thank you representative
Lucas I think um just due to time and
how it's going I would like to give a
little bit of time just to hear from the
state employees Association
um and their take on this all right
thank you
probably not a ton of time but a little
bit of time while he's setting up who's
going to write who's going to take care
of the Amendments it's going to be
needed to clean up some of the things
that Dan talked about I'm assuming Tony
will work on it with Dan
make sure somebody's on
good morning thank you very much
um with your permission Mr chairman I
believe I have some
um I was only anticipating five I see
six not everybody's on the subcommittee
I I can certainly uh provide more
um so for the record uh Bob Blasdell
representing the state employees
Association good morning
um first I'd like to start off with um
with an apology uh when this bill was
initially heard uh public hearing I had
a family emergency and was not able to
attend so I apologize uh for that but I
certainly very much appreciate the
opportunity uh this morning
um
I guess first and foremost uh you know
this is in in your packet you're going
to see a letter from the state employees
um president uh Mr Rich gulla outlining
uh many of the concerns we have with
this piece of legislation
um so far I believe this we've seen the
as introduced version we've seen the
amendment presented at the public
hearing we've seen another amendment
this morning and on the Fly this morning
we're seeing additional edits so we're
essentially on to like the fourth
version of of this which should
hopefully uh bring you to a pause
um this is a very serious matter you're
dealing with
um the the
Financial futures of thousands of
individuals who work very very hard for
the state our state
um so I guess first question would be
out of the box is who's asking for this
I can tell you as representing the state
employees Association we certainly are
not
um
you'll see in your packet this this blue
one of these blue again I apologize um
somebody put a trick on me this morning
put blue paper into the printer
um I apologize for the obnoxious color
but you'll see here
um with Florida and North Dakota South
Dakota South Carolina excuse me in
Colorado when employees are given a a
choice of the matter but between a
defined benefit and a defined
contribution plan it's overwhelming 76
percent in Florida chose defined benefit
North Dakota and 98 South Carolina 82
percent Colorado 88 percent
um we just don't necessarily see where
this is coming from when you look at the
legislative history which is also
stapled to president gullah's testimony
or letter you'll see the legislative
history going all the way back to the
year 2000.
with I've been I've included all of the
blurbs
from all of those inexpedient to
legislate motions that were adopted by
both Republican and Democrat
legislatures
um it's
certainly been the course of this
legislature over the years to to review
everything to see if there's something
that we can do better
again I hope we can all pause here
because
um
everywhere we go in this legislature and
these Halls this legislative session all
we hear is recruitment retention
recruitment retention that's where we're
at
this is not a bill that emphasizes
retention in fact I've heard many people
say this is portable this is portable
um encouraging the portability of this
but I do want to make one
um clear note here it's been suggested
that the current plan that we have is
not portable
I would suggest to you this morning that
it is portable it's portable within the
first 10 years
in legislatures in the past very wisely
set up this system to protect the
taxpayer dollars
what does that mean
that means that taxpayer dollars are
going in for the first 10 years along
with the employee contributions and if
that employee so chooses to leave before
they're vested that employee is portable
they can leave with their money but not
the taxpayers money
okay when they invest in this state
they're rewarded by by working hard for
the state and they become vested now the
monster events did now the taxpayers say
thank you here's your pension
so right now the system we have protects
the taxpayer money
right and it is portable but that
employee just takes their their their
chunk of the money that they invested
over the nine and a half years
so I wanted to make sure that was that
was clear
um
you've got a lot of material there
um in your in your you've got the week
off next week some of you
um hopefully you'll be able to have a
chance to to review it
um
I want to make sure that
we understand
the guesswork potentially by these
potential group three employees about
having to make the right choices for
their financial future
um I consider myself halfway educated
fairly intelligent
um I know I get my my informational
packets from Merrill Lynch
um every now and again and I can't make
heads or tails of it
um I don't consider myself to be in a
position to be making decisions
um to to make I that's what I asked the
experts for right I ask for those people
to to guide me through that
the issue with the defined contribution
plan is
there there's no guarantee right
when you look at the stock market which
is all this is based on right
the four Worst Years
in the stock market's history
okay four I'm shooting out of the ten
worst years excuse me out of the 10
worst years ever in the history of the
stock market four of them happened in
this century
four of them in the last 22 years
so if you happen to be one of those
unfortunate individuals to to have to
sometimes have to retire or choose to
retire in those down years when your
investment just plummets okay and you
have a 401k
there's no guarantee that you're going
to be able to to have access to the to
those funds in its completion for the
rest of your life you may cannibalize
that in the first eight years of your
retirement and then what
cost shifting is a very real issue which
I have not heard yet debated
okay in the future let's say push this
out 30 40 years we have a group three
and these people retire
and they outlive the Investments of
their defined contribution
where do they go
I'll tell you where they go they go back
onto the roles of the state
because that's what happens
that's what happens so the cost shifting
right there I hope everybody again
please pause and think about that about
what that does to not only the
individual putting them in that
situation but also the taxpayers of the
state
it's
it's concerning
um whereas obviously a defined benefit
you have that for the rest of your life
until the day you die and you can count
on it
you know I I you know I wasn't able to
attend the hearing but I was able to
listen to it online
and good friend of my good friend the
most of ours here is just really quickly
maybe like three more minutes or so oh
three minutes okay three three five tops
yeah I'm on the clock yeah I'm just
watching the clock a little bit all
right
um
okay there was a there was a comment
um made by representative McGuire
earlier this morning
um about
should we should this legislature decide
to move forward
um with the the group three that
um there's there's nothing I believe um
said Madam chair mentioned um that their
retirement can't be screwed with
um
I would take
um issue with that comment only because
I know that this state is the only state
in the country
I believe I stand corrected but I
believe it's the only state in the
country that actually put forward
retroactive changes to the New Hampshire
Retirement System
so I would suggest to you that yeah
although they they will have their money
like 100 invested right away however
that's not to say that 10 15 years from
now we're sitting at this very table and
we're talking about a hybrid
maybe a hybrid but have to find benefit
half half contribution plan so there are
what we've witness is that we know that
the legislature can make changes
um so nothing's nothing certainly set in
stone
just for clarification on that point if
those members had been vested that they
wouldn't have been able to have been
retroactively affected so the vestment
was the point of contention in the
courts just for clarification on that
correct but what we witnessed was that
there can be changes made absolutely
um so I know I'm on the clock here I'll
I'll keep that ask questions as well
just as far as the overall testimony
yeah so I would just ask to
um please obviously you're going to do
your due diligence and and be very
thoughtful about this
um
foreign
it up to any questions now and I
appreciate your time this morning yeah
uh representative Schmidt
thank you Mr thank you Mr chairman and
Bob thank you very much for being here
today because we certainly want to hear
from all sides
all rational sides anyway
um so uh the the legislative history
that is appended to the letter from Mr
Gullah uh I was one of the people who
got the letter so I I did see some of
that uh and was able to kind of think
through it and look through it uh but is
it not the case that this proposed plan
is quite different from uh the previous
plans as I understand it anyway in that
the many of the previous ideas or
concepts that were it out all of them uh
were a some form of here's what you got
now we're going to switch switch that to
something completely well not completely
different but fundamentally different
from you know one was defined benefit
when it was going to go to Define
contribution whereas this is I
understand it and please tell me if I've
got it wrong or if you see it
differently that the uh we are in this
planner the sponsors that we we haven't
done it yet
um
are saying here's your current plan
that's going to stay
and all the commitments have been made
so the uaal is still going to be
continued to be funded by the employers
um and uh the people are still going to
have their defined benefit and so forth
and this and group three is going to be
something
added on is that not the case or is that
is that your understanding
the earlier plans that were all i t out
if I understand your your question
representative is is you know basically
what's what's the difference from the
past into what we have in front of us
today
um the difference is being I know in the
past
um they were very very good fiscal notes
associated with with the bills in the
past I do see an FN associated with this
bill number however I've never I haven't
I've seen corrected I haven't seen what
it's going to cost the state
in terms of uh the first couple of years
of implementing this plan I I haven't
seen the additional cost of the of the
ual by picking up the cost of the group
three people so that's that's a
difference I guess in a question of not
knowing what the finances are and I
understand this isn't going to finance
so again I create hopefully some great
pause there
um as far as the group three if I
understand your question please tell me
if I'm going down the wrong Rabbit Hole
here representative but
um the difference being this time around
um it does not include firefighters
police teachers as all the versions in
the past have
um that's that's my understanding and
again stand corrected but the
legislative history that I'm aware of
this is the first time this is just
targeted towards state employees
I as far as I remember that is correct
it is
um
it's definitely the first time that it
is limited to State Employees group one
because
the characteristics of group one and
group two are significantly different
so this says you know a defined benefit
pension makes a lot more sense for group
two who are
essentially committing to Public Service
their entire careers then to the state
employees who are not necessarily so
I would um
with all due respect Madam chair there
are many members thousands of members
that view the state of New Hampshire
working for them in group one state
employees as their career and they're
very proud of it wasn't saying that that
there were not career employees I'm
saying that not all group one are career
employees
even if you have a career say as a civil
engineer you might work for the state
and then go work for oddly or whatever
sure I also understand
um I I know
um several people who are former
teachers former firefighters former
police officers that after a couple of
First Years on the job they decide you
know what I'm going to be a real estate
agent I'm going to go sell insurance
um so uh to to try and say that all
group two employees or teachers that's
their career and that's their sentence
no I would I would say no that's not the
case
teachers less so but that's that
teachers are in a different situation
and that there are so many
many employers compared to the state
any other questions
thank you for joining us I really
appreciate your time yeah thank you
enjoy your break
uh representative leak is just really
quickly
um one more thing
yes
uh yes uh so in the creation of this
um it's mandatory for all future members
to be part of the defined contribution
plan
um was the concern over the
uh pool of money uh being large enough
and therefore needing all of those
employees or is there a reason why we
didn't offer the option to stay in the
Divine benefit as opposed to you know
just the biggest reason
um the problem is
it you know if something is optional I
mean even if people in general like it
it may take time for people to decide
this is something they want news to get
out whatever and the problem is if that
fund grows too slowly
then
um you know either the state would have
to pay for administration at least part
of it longer
or
um
the administrative costs would consume
too high a percentage of the employees
contributions with them resulting in
them having a
uh very poor return or Worse yeah that
makes sense I just wanted a
clarification
um any other questions guys for Tony
thank you representative appreciate it
yeah and when I see that information I
think I am the prime sponsor may get
together and yeah come up with a
obviously we're not scoring the circle
today so yeah
um we need the finalized Amendment
version from you anyway so we'll be
meeting again on this one for sure thank
you
as it turns out an extra copy of the
letter from
the letter from Mr Gullah
anybody on the committee opposed to us
moving off of 559 for now we'll have to
come back to it
I would just like to make one comment
addressing something that was stated at
the hearing uh it was foot forward that
uh there were the individual had doubts
about the constitutionality of the
current pension program based on section
36 which was instituted in 1784 I would
say that folks back then really did not
understand pension programs and it was
certainly a different animal than what
we see today and I would point out
further that
the state Constitutional Convention
which was comprised of 400 members in
1984 200 years later chose to amend that
section with 36a to protect the Pension
funds so I think if they had doubts
about the constitutionality of the plan
at that time that answers the quest
question that it is in fact
constitutional thank you
I'm not sure we were planning on
ripping the whole thing out by the roots
anyway but
um all right um I would like to move on
to
um 461.
uh representative Pearson if you would
love to like to join us
this uh this being a work session we
needed to um
discuss
modifications there was some suggestions
made
um
during the public hearing
and uh I did oh for the record
representative C Pierce in Rockingham
District 13 Dairy
the original thought process that with
of this really surrounded group two and
and as discussions were had during the
public hearing
um about group one's inclusion in this
as well
and then there was substantial
discussion about
handcuffing the downsizing of
specifically school districts and their
employees and how this may potentially
inhibit that
so between the public hearing and some
hallway discussions in reference to
really where the abuses are versus it
not being a global problem within those
systems it's generally just based on
some of the top tier positions
there was some discussion is as to
modifying this
in order to just
cover those type positions yeah I my
concern initially with it was that it's
perhaps to different issues
um and would you consider
focusing primarily on the downshifting
from a full-time position to a part-time
position for now one of the one of the
concerns I have is that there's a pretty
easy work around for reducing the number
of employees especially in
the situation we find ourselves in right
now which is that a municipality could
just leave that position on the books
and not fill it and say well we still
have it but it's not filled and to me
that would seem like it would be a
pretty easy work around to
reduce you know if you reduce the number
of employees now they're on the hook for
the liability well only if they get rid
of the position but what if they don't
fill the position keep it on the books
but don't fill it
gotcha
so I suppose that would be a similar
workaround to them
well I guess it wouldn't no not in that
case so so this is you're looking what
you're what I'm getting at from your
representative Simon is more along the
lines of a reclassification
from Full to part rather than
elimination yeah so I got you there okay
I mean I think I think I just think it's
more workable sure and that's really
what's that's really the what's going on
anyway so
so with that being said we did discuss
that this would be or there was
discussions in reference to
top tier positions versus
all positions
if in and I think that in this
particular case it would be prudent
perhaps to address the areas we know
where there's a problem and if we have a
more Global problem later we could
certainly come back and make
modifications but
um hang on one second there Steve any
any comments from the committee yeah
I was in on the hallway discussions and
I agree that the abuses that this bill
is intended to address are the top tier
positions there's not a problem if
Epsom decides it doesn't need a
full-time emergency coordinator
I mean we're still going to have as many
police or fires as before we're just
not going to have that position be full
time the trouble is with the police
Chiefs the administrators
School administrators
uh
possibly fire captains although that I
haven't heard of any cases no it's
um
so
and in those cases the abuse is that
they take an existing full-time position
and declare
declare it to be part-time and hire a
retiree to fill it
so that the the employer doesn't have to
pay the into the retirement system at
all if they're hiring a part-time person
and they can offer a somewhat lower
salary because it's part-time and the
person is already collecting their
pension
is that the problem you're seeking to
yeah I mean that that in the fact that
the municipality then whether would
there be no contribution to the
retirement system they get out of not
only the payment the normal portion of
that but also the uaal portion so
if we're looking at that those types of
positions we're talking superintendents
principles administrators Fire Chiefs
police Chiefs I did write down the word
director
I don't know if that how that title fits
into something but I and then
sub variations of that as as in
assistance and deputies with the
exception of law enforcement because the
sheriff's department calls their Rank
and file deputies and that's again we're
not looking at Rank and file here so
what I'm trying to get from the
committee here is is exactly how the
framework how how to frame this
amendment and that's that's really the
the discussion that we need to have here
as far as as far as
the the titles of folks that would be
included in this top tier type
look you could also put a salary limit
you know the top 10 percent of salaries
in the department
that um
that may become problematic in the sense
that there are police departments where
the top 10 percent of salaries will not
include their police chief
really for the salary they don't have
any overtime uh well I meant salary not
not pay so okay
Maybe baseball
we had a situation in Dover where there
was one police officer who was working
every detail he could get because he had
a bunch of kids so he was working
everything so he had a very high net pay
uh but a gross pay I guess uh but it was
not salary or base pay so that that
difference has to be spelled out yeah I
mean that happens everywhere sure sure
so okay so then you know I'm just trying
to I have to think of this I have to
think of Fitzwilliam versus Manchester
and
something with the word notch in it in
it versus Nashua right because this has
to this is a global this is a global law
so it's got a tiny little town versus
our larger communities and and how does
this work
um if I can just get a sense from the
committee though if we are just going to
keep this to
um top-tier employees and we're really
just trying to deal with the issue of
them moving from full-time to part-time
in order to circumvent the New Hampshire
retirement system is that something for
the most part the committee would be
interested in hearing back on
is that is that better than the original
it's a real problem and and it's an
abuse of the system and I think if we
can figure out a way to get at it yeah
we ought to do it so
um yeah so I mean I don't Carol go ahead
yeah I agree we it it is a problem
for the
the people that hear about it and it's
an incentive for other towns to do the
same thing absolutely uh I I have on a
totally separate issue the
the penalty you have here is in
perpetuity
and I think that's I think that's well
the retirement system assumed it was so
uh well we need to be explicit I would
suggest something like for 10 years or
until the full-time position is restored
it says at line seven
if the position is restored or group two
contributing position the penalty shall
be terminated in the normal calculations
for retirement system contributions will
be restored
we want to incentivize them thank you
very much I miss that to do it to to do
things right so we certainly don't want
to lock them into a problem so unless
there's unless there's anything else
from the committee on this and it's fine
that there is
um yes I know we did talk about the uh
look back
retroactive if you will I assume that
yeah line 10 can go away that can be
gone representative
uh
just trying to clear up the fog that's
always surrounded me that's right
um
so we're talking about people
a few people
yes just a few people you always say a
fog but you're always right on the stick
representative
who
were eligible to retire yes did so
nothing illegal there correct
and because they retire they're not
paying into the retirement system
anymore
and if the town wants to hire them back
as part-time but pay them the same kind
of seller of salary potentially
but just call it part-time work so they
don't have to pay into the system
dissipating employer which is everybody
and every government unit in the state
you your pension is suspended and you
make further contributions in the
retirement system if you're lucky
you might get a raise and your pension
are more years of service and your
pension might increase
if you decide to retire and collect your
pension you can work part-time
but only for a limited number of hours
which is
um actually incredibly generous but we
won't go into that that's a different
bill so it's a different issue but but
if you are working part-time neither you
nor your employer pays into the
retirement system for you for that
position so you're double dipping you're
keeping your job and you're collecting
your pension at the same time and the
issue is that the
if you're unscrupulous
you declare yourself working part-time
and with your employer's consent and
they'll pay you some amount part-time
and you'll still collect your pension
and I realized double tipping is is a
nasty uh well it's uh not populous uh to
the people who are paying taxes for that
school administrator both of the town
manager or whatever
but isn't that the town's choice I mean
well you left off one part the town is
also getting out of its debt that it is
required to pay and that's where that's
a big that's a bigger issue with this
than probably anything else yeah it
probably wouldn't be such a problem if
the uaal didn't exist but because it
does
they're taking that job off of the off
of the payroll let's say for
downshifting the debt so that's going to
get pushed off to other communities to
pick up that burden
um because the debt doesn't go away
they're just not paying their portion of
it now for the position that they should
be paying
does that make sense yeah
sorry that would that be the biggest
problem I think in 2000 you know um 2040
this isn't necessarily as big of a deal
in 2040 100a is going to probably be
substantially Rewritten anyway
so we'll cross that bridge when all of
us are talking to other legislators
about it and also I mean if it if it is
a concern would there be a problem with
putting a sunset clause in once the uial
is fully funded if you want I I'm not
opposed to that the thing of it is that
we're asking them to
[Music]
and
I would I would feel better if we just
said it's a uaal contribution because
they don't the person is not earning any
further benefits
as a part-time employee so the normal
cost is not necessary
but sure that's a tiny amount of the uh
right normal cost of the pension the
pension system is extremely low I mean
that's why the
that's why we created the pension system
in 67 because it's far cheaper so than
doing it any other way so it's so sure I
mean that's that's really the ual part
of this part of this is is really the
majority of right the the problem here
you're just you just don't want to shift
costs right it's not fair for dairy I
mean representative true and I border
towns it's not fair if my town decides
to to come up with this this scheme all
I'm doing is Shifting that debt over to
his town and everybody else's town and
that's that's just not
this this has got a little bitty fire
going on right now under it and if you
know we've we've spent six years quietly
talking about fixing this
and then it happened again so we have
got to nip this in the bud before this
becomes a a tactic
any other questions it may have already
become a tactic it just is not very
widespread yet right
so keep it on the down low so they don't
hear us talking no okay so so uh
yeah I assure you this isn't something
that within especially the group two
World everyone is well aware of yeah
um so if you want representative to work
on an amendment and we are happy to help
with input on that um well that's that's
why I'm talking to you now in in this in
this forum really just just so that
because like I said my thought with this
is that if we're if we're going to look
at the positions where this has happened
or
or potentially could happen then we're
talking about superintendents principals
administrators fire chief police chief
and potentially the title of director
yeah Direct ly direct name what it's
called sure if it's the same kind of
thing
so if we did use the phrase and the
light because I'm not really familiar
with seeing that in statute very much
OLS might have a different term that
becomes uh right all us to figure it out
there's a legal term
yeah however however the the lawyers
will phrase such a thing and then
everybody can chop and say it's too
vague to enforce
well well you'd have litigation yeah
would the term administrative position
senior administrator I mean you're
talking senior Personnel yes well the
other thing that yeah because the other
thing that you don't want to leave is a
loophole is the whatever the
organization is just changes the name so
it doesn't match up with the statute and
then they're like well it isn't a fire
chief it's uh whatever and yeah it's a
fire leader exactly sure of course all
right and that
everybody laughs at that until the first
Community does it they'll do it for sure
and then right that's what this that's
what city of Franklin did that they were
the first ones to ever ever kind of get
on this road and that's exactly what
they did they had an emergency
management or Emergency Operations
director some some bizarre title that
was not fire chief and not police chief
so there's well in statute it only says
this and this
yeah so
so I agree we'll we'll ask for that
the legalese of that concept sure sure
okay well then uh then we'll have
another work session you can bring it
back to it and we'll take a look at it
yep that works and uh now that we've got
a framework here
we'll go from there sure cool awesome
awesome thank you so much I'll run that
by you before I file it okay that sounds
good we can just discuss it well we'll
discuss it I'll pass it around get some
feedback from everybody else and then we
can send it in okay so that way you're
not showing up and then we're totally
revamping it and having to have a third
work session right yeah right gotcha all
right fantastic cool thank you thank you
everybody all set on this bill any other
all right
representative Bernardi thank you so
much for being so patient and listening
to all of our fascinating conversation
[Laughter]
I'm going to move to 457 and welcome
representative Bernardi who has some
further information to share with us
let's be
so for the record uh representative JD
Bernardi Rockingham 36 which is Hampton
Falls Kensington Southampton Newton and
Plaistow
and what I've provided you uh is a an
article about our attorney general
joining
a lawsuit recently
exactly focused on the topic of of this
uh the principle of this legislation
which is that the ESG investing and it
could be any kind of uh investing that
is not standard uh using standard
fiduciary duty you know pecuniary
responsibility only not some other uh
Factor social justice whatever it is
um is is inappropriate and uh as the
federal government has has changed the
laws or is in the process of changing
the laws to uh permit this
um and uh we have multiple states that
are now suing the federal government to
stop the implementation of that rule
and the rationale is highlighted in
yellow at the bottom ESG funds generally
gain
a 6.3 percent return compared to an 8.9
return for the average Market
so there are multiple surveys that are
out there and in the testimony that
happened on the on the bill when it was
heard you heard people make the claims
that yes you can be this and can be that
and you can look at
you know whatever survey you want but in
general
I believe it is accepted that in the
current climate any of these ESG funds
or non
straight fiduciary duty oriented funds
will have a lower rate of return
the CEO of BlackRock made the statement
that we need to do this for about 10
years or so in order to change the way
the world works and then this won't be a
problem anymore so just accept it
so that's
that's the principle behind the
legislation the second article in the in
the stack just describes what the
court cases and the other two documents
I've provided you were were the
documents I referenced in my testimony
um and uh unfortunately I I did not have
the ability to give you at at that time
so with that I'm I'm
ready to entertain whatever questions
you may have
any questions from the committee
yes representative McGuire
good morning I see that our attorney
general has said that
um
that that that
the fiduciary should Place their clients
interest at the Forefront which is New
Hampshire law and New Hampshire
Constitution and the issue you're trying
to stop is a federal law and I don't see
how a state law can block a federal law
uh
so
when I reviewed the law with OLS
um
the treasure does not have a fiduciary
duty to make investments according to a
you know traditional fiduciary duty
responsibility there's nothing in in in
those statutes that requires that
um the
pension laws say that one should use
sole interest which I can argue and I
think many would argue is even higher
standard traditional fiduciary duty
the question that I have is whether or
not that is indeed being done
um and so the purpose of this was to
drive home that point that one should be
looking at that and I asked in my
testimony uh that the the Pension funds
be asked whether or not they are
actually using the sole interest law or
fiduciary duty responsibility in their
investment activities or are they
turning it over to most
many Pension funds are run by by turning
the actual voting of shares and buying
and processing of those shares over to a
proxy that
doesn't look at these things
so if it's listed on the exchange it's
okay you know if they they are not
looking at the underlying criteria like
whether they're pursuing ESG or some
other
um factors beyond straight fiduciary
duty which is why you have 25 states
that are now stirring the pot here
saying this is wrong
to follow up on that question though
um and you know I share your feelings on
ESG as a general rule for sure I'm just
trying to parse out you know what's
going on in this particular bill
is your main concern simply that the
state of New Hampshire is
making Investments with fiduciary
responsibility in the Forefront or as
the main concern that we just aren't
investing in ESG at all
the reason why I asked the question is
what if the two coincide on a in a
particular fund whereas both they both
are
um take ESG into consideration but it is
also producing the highest return that's
available to the state of New Hampshire
and just following up on that my
question would be
would it meet your goal to just put into
statute that the treasurer does have to
take fiduciary responsibility into
consideration when making Investments
um and leave the ESG component of it out
uh from your perspective well I don't
the the law itself does not say anything
about BSG The Proposal it just says
um
let me find it here
social political or ideological
interests I mean that that's the part
that I'm getting at it doesn't say ESG
but that's I mean that's the general
idea of it now the analysis section uh
says that but the but the proposal
that's in order to make it clear what
what this focus is but the law uh
actually being proposed is all
Investments and their management shall
be governed by fiduciary duty to
maximize benefits to the state and the
beneficiaries of States trust funds
that's it so it doesn't matter if it's
ESG or if it's uh some other
criteria the bottom line is
whoever is managing the fund should
manage them for maximum return
period
right no no other no other common or no
other criteria should be blended into
that right no I understand so that's my
that's my question is if we were to make
an amendment to this bill that basically
just said that the treasury because the
New Hampshire retirement system from our
understanding is already under that
obligation the concern is that the
treasury isn't under that obligation if
we just rewrote it to say that the
treasury is under that obligation with
that meet your concerns
it would meet my concern however I again
I I would ask that I am not sure that
the treasure is I mean excuse me the
pension fund system is following that
responsibility
your sole interest so maybe Carol would
know this better than me I'm sure she
would actually know this better than me
um who oversees whether or not the New
Hampshire retirement system is meeting
that fiduciary responsibility and who
can hold them accountable because the
same question would hold true to the
treasurer if we pass this on to the
treasurer
um
I don't know the
boarded the Board of Trustees of the
retirement system
is it stated that they shall I had they
had they are fiduciaries
and any person who is a beneficiary that
thinks they aren't not investing solely
for the benefit of the
beneficiaries can sue them
I don't believe there is any specific
entity that is checking up on them
regularly that's what you're asking yeah
well I don't know at all we got even if
we put that clause in say we were to say
that they had to ask whether or not they
were taking those other things into
consideration
um
the question still comes back to
accountability who's holding them
accountable to that who's looking after
them to say did you ask or was the
paperwork that you asked or
um that would be the next question
that's that's the premise of why I
brought this
right but even if we were to pass this
as written yeah who who's holding them
accountable so now they're supposed to
do this but who's coming on the backside
and holding them accountable for it
how would we know
I I would say basically the
lead quite a bit of concern a few years
back when the Retirement System's
earnings came in at I believe it was 1.5
percent when everyone else was earning
12 and at that point the legislature
passed a bill that they had to
post on the website the amounts that
they were spending in investment
who they were spending money with to
invest the monies of which corporations
and how much I would also find out that
the Investments for the retirement
system are actually done by an
independent investment committee
appointed by the Board of Trustees
correct right I would also have the
fiduciary duty yes definitely they are
all
fiduciaries and have that responsibility
I would also point out that the state
treasurer is answerable to the
legislature gets reelected every two
years
but there isn't like a standing
committee on finance or anything that's
specifically oversees Investments
and would for the treasurer or for the
New Hampshire retirement system there's
no there's no standing committee that
oversees that
Carol Le DNA does look at the retirement
system fairly often but we don't
necessarily dig down into whether or not
they're making changes
um so potentially that could be an
amendment that would say
there shall be a
committee that
investigates whether this fiduciary
standard is being upheld yeah I'm just
trying to drill down to make sure that I
understand I'm you know meeting your
concerns with the bill which is
primarily that fiduciary responsibility
is the Paramount concern and that
somebody's watching to make sure that
the institutions that are investing are
investing
with that in mind yes the the retirement
system
does issue
issue their minutes are public they do
issue reports and they send it to me
ex-officio and I noticed that for
example when the federal government said
you know don't invest in Russia they had
a plan to divest Russian
assets
which they identified as being very
risky and not a lot but not not a large
Port part of their portfolio
and I understand it's uh so
um
I believe I I also looked at the at the
site and they're publishing their
returns uh you know because yeah yes 10
or so years ago we were down to one and
a half percent and and then while
everybody else is making uh over 10
percent in their returns uh so the focus
is on their rate of return but there is
no focus on whether or not this
uh infiltration idea that you can invest
both for fiduciary or pecuniary return
and social justice concerns at the same
time which
will drag your your returns down
somewhat but maybe not so bad that you
wouldn't notice it that who's watching
for that that's that's the concern we're
looking at here
those who care
I mean that's legitimately if you think
that they're investing in a way that
that jeopardizes their returns
you're an interested party you're
bringing in a bill I mean what
if you and to be to be honest looking at
the returns of the retirement system I'd
say they are not worse than other
Retirement Systems but they sure look a
whole lot more more highly variable
volatile they're definitely more
volatile
um
another thought potentially
should should some oversight of either
Finance or Edna
um should we request reports comparing
the returns of our system to similar
systems around the country they give
they give them
we do get them okay yeah I'll show you
the stack of
okay
um and do we know if the treasury does
the same thing
foreign
they send out quarterly and I look at it
and I skim it for you know obvious
issues and then I put it on the stack
and then when the stack gets too high I
take out the bottom exactly so but I'm
not as concerned about these issues as
you obviously are
and and speaking from the other side of
Edna I would say we aren't either it's a
matter of how much they're making uh not
so much how they're making it what kind
of decisions they're making as far as
maximizing the income
well dealing with the Gnomes of Zurich
I'm I'm happy with that
provided of course they get a reasonable
return
well again the concept is is clear that
if you are trying to serve two masters
your returns are going to be slightly
lower that's the issue well I I feel
like if if the treasurer isn't under a
fiduciary obligation and statute we
should look to we should look to fix
that I mean I would say that I would say
that is something that we ought to
include that the treasurer is does have
a fiduciary responsibility because
she's got millions of dollars of State
money rainy day fund plus all the
operating funds all the lost money all
all the in
a
you definitely need
responsibility because some of that
stuff sticks around for a while
um I would say that before we take that
step though we should have the treasurer
or a representative come in and and
address this issue
directly with this subcommittee because
there may be
um conditions that we're not considering
are hearing yeah I think I think
bringing the treasurer in and maybe some
uh somebody from OLS who can explain
that side of it as well someone from the
treasurer's office I would say I would
say yeah I just meant uh someone from
the lawyer side as well to interpret the
statute and and what is obligated or not
the first year we're considering this
bill would they be able to provide to
meet with this have somebody meet with
the subcommittee yeah
because
it doesn't look like
um
because when you read it they're talking
about costs to check into whether or not
their current suppliers are compliant
they're not saying we don't have a
fiduciary
I don't think that they're saying they
don't feel they have a fiduciary
responsibility
so but we all definitely ought to talk
to them
parameters
okay I'll take care of that I'll contact
the treasurer and see if they can have a
um representative meet with us to
discuss whether or not
and then um if need be we can check in
with
OLS and see if
their interpretation is
the same
[Laughter]
so we can get multiple uh opinions on it
and then we can discuss it further and
and see what uh
we do have the concept we do want to
make sure that all of our institutions
are taking fiduciary responsibility as
the primary concern for our investments
I think we're all agreed on that
um so this will we'll do that we'll have
another meeting looks like we are going
to have another meeting on all three of
these bills
um and hopefully we can Chip Away them a
little bit more than we have until the
16th
eighth
the exact is scheduled for the eighth
eighth okay so the
uh we do have till the 15th to actually
complete all of the bills but they're
scheduled for the eighth
uh I have spoken with representative
Smith and we can use this room is
available to us
for Mondays as well as Fridays
seeing as how we're losing our they're
only going to be here on Tuesdays
we're losing our Thursdays to session so
Mondays and Fridays are available okay
sorry
uh well Chris Chris wanted me to miss it
for the world so
um any any other comments uh from the
committee that we should take into
consideration as we push forward with us
yes representative are we expecting an
amendment
um we still talk
I would I would say we should talk to
the treasurer first
you know I'm regardless of this issue I
think just simply saying that the
treasurer does have a fiduciary
responsibility I'm sure that
this has to be the case well I'm sure
it's assumed but I don't know where it
is in statute 10 years vested has been
assumed for 60 years as well
at least I'd be happy
I would say everybody on the committee
would would support
clarifying that the treasurer does have
a fiduciary duty provided there's no
Zinger so we don't know about or there's
there may be something somewhere else
good
representative Bernardi thank you for
your time and we're gonna we'll keep you
posted on as we continue to work on this
thing
and um
unless anybody has anything else that's
uh
I mean the end of the uh
subcommittee meeting
well these were on the docker for our
next meeting but no longer
they are on the docket for the exec
session because
all the bills are listed we we can
recess and reschedule and we probably
will
yes yes there are